[Music]
so I did New Orleans yeah and
um
it's cool is it you know I kissed our
plaque oh same venue
same thing nice
you know just laid a little yeah a
little ginger a ginger a little kiss on
it
just for some good luck
it was a good show uh some drunk woman
uh heckled the [__] out of me randomly
it turned out to be really
dude this [__] was so funny you know I'm
[__] around I like kind of just to
the crowd I'm like we having a good time
everyone's like yeah
then this drunk lady stands up and she
goes
in just the abyss I'm [__] leaving
before I call you a [__]
okay and it just pierced the whole room
everyone in the room just turned to her
like what
and yeah literally just like that and
she's sitting kind of off to the side
and then I said I was like what are you
I saw I kind of started questioning her
like is this for real like what could
you possibly be mad at and then uh
actually no I think what I did say I was
like oh no it's like you're leaving oh
no bye
[Laughter]
but so she kind of starts like chirping
and I'm chirping back a little bit and I
realize she's wasted so you know I dial
it back but what I didn't see was in the
darkness I guess she was on a date and
as she was chirping at me the dude is
kind of tapping her to be like no no
it's like stop stop stop and then as she
chirps more
he moved away one seat because they were
at like a fourth four top table and so
he kind of moved back and then while she
kept chirping he just he just took off
he just ditched her
no wait wait you watched that whole
thing happen
or another part of it so was this part
of the crowd work
no I didn't even notice it really how so
who yeah I told you like you someone
like told you after
yeah Tom and a couple other people
mentioned after so because she was
wearing all white so I like the light
was hitting her shirt so I could like
kind of see her
um but the dude was dark dressed in dark
clothing I thought he was security
you just [__] left her ass yeah I'm
like that's so crazy to be like let's go
see the show tonight and then she's like
not you and he's like yeah not I did not
sign up for this [__]
yeah no I'm good oh Maddie [__]
that's incredible that to be so bad I
left it heckling that your date leaves
you
I mean there's like no way that you
could lose harder than that right
no and and she like kind of drunk at
some point I said look I don't have a
problem with you just sit your ass down
and like just relax and she sat there
for a while and then eventually she left
because I think I think she felt so bad
um
next to her and she's like wait where
the [__] did the she's like laughs in
one of your jokes and looks to see if
the guy's laughing he's just not there
and then she laughs and looks back at
the front and the lights are all on and
I'm fully off stage and she's like how
am I still here
security screaming you gotta go oh
you're up well you woke up man you gotta
go
good morning
hey sleepy heads over the next door it's
just open for the for the next show yeah
hi it's now Sunday and uh it's it's
Monday actually today's a holiday so you
have to leave now
you have to go that's good yeah so then
I so we went out to Bourbon Street
and grenade
no I just but I burnt the [__] on my
tongue on a pizza so that sucked okay
hell yeah man that's what bourbon
Street's all about baby yeah Bourbon
Street goes crazy roof of my mouth is
feeling it you know what I'm saying
I got so [__] up last night on Bourbon
Street my tongue is [__] up dude
you hard on some [__] Bourbon Street
Pizza like you're supposed to and cut
the [__] out of my roof of my mouth and
my tongue is all burnt up man I went so
hard
I [__] my tongue up last night on
Bourbon Street oh you eat some [__] man
nah I just ate a really hot pizza
extra chili Flex on there
[__] hurts so bad
it actually does hurt I haven't like
been able to drink water enjoyably for
the last like day and a half that's the
worst pain um we were watching some guys
you know like a like a makeshift drum
line and they're all like half naked
playing the drums humping the ground and
[__] dude it was it was The Grind On Me
Vine ERA with live instrumentation it
was so nice it was just so funny so
while these guys are performing we're
kind of like looking around like oh
maybe you know I wonder if there's like
a pickpocket that's gonna like show up
or something because the crowd is pretty
big
and then I was thinking like imagine a
pickpocket like tries to go into your
pocket and you feel it and
he thinks he gets like you're like your
phone or something but he just grabs
your dick and you just grab his wrist
and then you look at him and he's like
and you're like take your hand back he's
like trying to take it back and you're
pushing it back in and he's like what is
this he's like I don't know what is it
why don't you try to take it yeah take
it go take it come on grab it yeah
he's like I don't want to take he's like
no no come on take it no take it that's
what you wanted right you wanted to
steal something right so steal it yeah
take some take take a little come way
don't you
he's trying to pull his hand and you
pull his hand back in and before you
know it he's just jacking you off in
your pants
Jesus Christ
there's some kind of Hoodie like give me
my hand back now come on feels so good
when you steal from me
laughs
oh you're taking a lot from me I'm just
gonna steal that tell you steal it
you're giving more than you're taking
come on pal in my night early send me
home
take me for all I'm worth
give me my handbag no
you can have your hand back once I'm
finished Jesus Christ
sorry sorry no just keep going you can
have my phone at the end you just have
my phone
you can have it all
foreign
mentality because
while I was eating the pizza
there was a you know the girls that
carry the the shots in the
in the little [__] yeah medical vials
yeah there was one of those girls and
she was just some old guy in the pizza
place and she was getting him [__] up
she would pour one of those vials like
on her chest okay and the dude would
like he was like some old guy old little
guy
and he would just like lick the shots
off her [__] chest like her tits like
New Orleans baby
in bright light he's just going crazy
like that yeah at a pizza place at a
pizza place dude and uh he's like you
know rubbing her thighs
and um
uh they're like kind of having some
argument and all we hear is no no give
me the 60 and then we'll do it after I
told you we'll do it after
than a roughly the old guy just kind of
marches up to the to the pizza counter
and he's like y'all got a bathroom
y'all got a bathroom in here
he's trying to go nah man we yeah oh wow
but we think she took him there knowing
that there's no bathroom and she's gonna
get them all [__] up and then just
take his 60 bucks and then run off yeah
yeah
probably that's probably what's gonna
happen
damn that's that's wild for him to be so
like
torqued and ready to go that he's trying
to [__] yeah
like dude there's like a million motels
around here you could probably go to
dude
we got [__] right now
yeah I know that's what he looked like
dude he looked like a [__] World of
Warcraft troll like he had this white
beard
work boots on yeah and he just you got
any room in the kitchen or a walk-in
freezer that we could just I'm anywhere
with that anywhere I'm quick it doesn't
even come anymore it doesn't even work
like that I'll be I'll be in and out of
there
I'll be so fast
dude walk in freezer with the shot girl
so yeah so like Bourbon Street it was
pretty quiet other than that grenade
that's like no I don't know it didn't
really feel like that kind of a night it
was a little bit it's still burnt I mean
it was still Bourbon Street but it's
very quiet for Bourbon Street yeah and
you know I don't really drink so I'm
just
uh yeah it was just like a pizza and
watch and we definitely saw some funny
things some other guy just like some big
dude stumbled out of a bar
and just loud as hell turns and he
starts pointing at this bar and he's
like [__] him
[__] him
[__] him and he's just walking backwards
he just keeps saying that
and then this and then he just starts
cussing randomly he's like [__]
piece of [__] okay is it this guy
walking by he just starts ad-libbing
everything the guy's saying he'll be
like [__] him yeah he'd be like [__] him
[__] [__] [__] [__]
and then he just pointed at us and
smiled and we just started crying
laughing and the drunk dude didn't get
it
when the guy was
we have no clue because then we looked
back and there was nothing happening at
the bar so we're like who is he I don't
know maybe his girl just left him at the
bar yeah